the Joe Rogan experience so you're
sitting pretty right now man I mean
you're at the top of the heap you're the
champ and you're you're the most popular
champ right now because you're the guy
who pulled off the giant upset over the
Olympic gold medalist the [ __ ] the
man Anthony Joshua you knock him out and
like that everyone is sitting there
chomping at the bit
there's Wilder who's you know probably
the greatest knockout artist in the
history the heavyweight division and
then there's Tyson Fury and Tyson Fury
and while they're trying to figure it
out and Tyson Fury's now in a different
organization it's a hard to make the
matches work now it's like what happens
next for you you know what's gonna be
next as the rematch against me and
Anthony Joshua we're still negotiating
but there's definitely gonna be the
rematch this year exciting fight but
yeah but uh while there you know while
there and me and him are on the same
team I had a little interview with him
over there at the Pacquiao fight and
really cool dude he's very cool yeah
he's really cool we respect each other
and but that I'll be a good fight you
know between me and him I love that well
I mean people knew who he was before but
goddamn that Tyson Fury fight put him on
the map what I was there too I was like
man I want to be in that position I want
to be champion it kind of motivated me
you know you know there well you know
and then his the the fight would Brazil
afterwards where he flatlined oh man at
one punch he's an interesting guy man
he's so interesting you know his story
that he didn't even start boxing until
he was like 20-something years old and
he really started doing it because of
his daughter because the daughter has
medical issues got it a limping team won
a bronze medal a year and a half in the
boxing that's crazy yeah it's nuts man
ladies bless you no yeah like you man
mm-hmm this is it yeah it's gotta be a
crazy feeling now for like six months
ago
you're the struggling boxer you know try
to make ends meet you know working your
way up very respected we don't have that
big name yet and then boom you get the
opportunity of all opportunities I think
that's what I need is just the
opportunity and
be hungry you know at from having
nothing to wanting to want something you
know in life it it's a big motivation
especially me I have five kids so damn
how old are you I'm 29 Wow it started
early
I know Mexican style yeah Mexican style
yeah well hey man your five kids are
sitting pretty now man yeah that's
beautiful
okay so you there's a rematch that is in
negotiation now how much can you tell us
that isn't a be in December sometime
December there's gonna be is gonna come
out pretty soon you know
you told me I did tell you about telling
anybody no don't
cameras are off okay yeah but it's gonna
be this year's and be an exciting fight
me and Anthony Joshua rematch
but the the words gonna come out soon or
isn't a bit if anything I'll message you
and be like oh yeah you know actually
you know well so now going into this
rematch is there anything that you're
gonna do differently I mean you know
obviously now that he's well aware
you're a big threat
mmm-hmm no he's gonna think about you me
I'm sure he was aware you were a threat
before but when you stopped him he
became the first guy to beat him I mean
that I mean that changes history mm-hmm
I think what we're gonna do we're we're
getting a big house over there in Mexico
somewhere in the in the nowheres you
know so we're gonna have a the suited a
camp you know close camp so we're just
gonna be really focused for this fight
we're not under estimating him or
anything you know we're just gonna work
hard and do it again so show people what
I'm capable of now how much change is
now that you're the champ do you have do
you change anything in your camp and as
far as your strength and conditioning as
far as long as we have all the team you
know the stuff that we need the
nutrition is the sheriff the coach is
you know the all the other stuff that I
need to to win this fight especially
training you know that's the main thing
training same discipline and
and I'm you know praying to God now I'm
coming into the fight with Josh with the
first time did you have any Trishna stid
you have a strength and conditioning
idea that I did have one the plan was
not to loose too much way you know
because the guy is really big you know I
wanted to be heavy so I could carry his
weight and you know it worked for my
favor but I think the main thing that
I'm gonna do I might do a little bit of
ways just to tighten up a little bit but
just stay busier that's the main thing
do you worry about like if it's not
broke don't fix it like there have been
guys before that have made changes in
the way they prepare and those changes
like maybe [ __ ] with their confidence or
they didn't feel as good they didn't
they didn't perform the same way no I
don't think we're gonna be changing too
much of that stuff you know long as rich
training we have the good sparring just
just exactly what we did for the last
fight I think that's what we're going to
be doing just more intense